tout d'abord vox populi vox dei comme
vous savez donc ce que dieu le peuple
veut dieu le veut les gens ont demandé
ici en particulier les catholiques ont
fait preuve de patience ils ont même eu
des expériences nouvelles les prêtres
aussi des expériences nouvelles de
communion spirituelle de rencontres à
travers évidemment les réseaux sociaux
les médias etc
mais au bout d'un moment il ya un grand
désir de se retrouver pour célébrer et
puis il ya une deuxième d une raison
c'est que nous avons l'assurance puisque
nous l'avons expérimenté déjà les
l'église catholique c'est une grosse
machine c'est parfois un peu lourd
parfois mais aussi un avantage c'est que
c'est une machine bien huilée et nous
avons l'assurance que nous pouvons
organiser des célébrations en respectant
à 100% les les gestes barrières et les
règles de sécurité
même au delà de ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui déjà dans les supermarchés
alors j'étais moi-même raison si vous me
permettez
ce sont les plus pauvres pardonnez moi
c'est ce sont les gens les plus pauvres
il ya toute une machine aussi caritative
d'ecoute d'accueil de voilà de rendre
service et on sent bien que il faut
mettre en oeuvre cette solidarité en
tant qu on ne peut pas se rassembler
elle est un peu grippé cette machine
envers les plus les plus nécessiteux